hello and welcome to episode number 44
of the weekly Google club back on
podcast hi I'm Francis Campo and I'm
here with my colleague mark Mendell hey
Mark hey Frances k are you doing today
very happy to have you back how was how
was strange look strangely was fantastic
that is definitely one of my favorite
conferences of the i'm very jealous of
the t shirt you're wearing right now I
think we should tweet a picture of that
yeah it's pretty amazing they had they
have a great strangest things themed
strangely t-shirt yeah it was on it is
vehicle I kinda want one now but anyway
so today we're gonna be talking with two
of our co-workers dense early and set
Abraham's are they're both working in
Google Cloud endpoints yeah we have a
really interesting conversation about
what endpoints is what it does why you'd
want to use it how you can use it not
just within Google Cloud but also cross
cloud it's not really really cool yeah
it is very interesting especially if you
are serving any kind of API I think that
it is worth for you listening to this
interview gonna learn some stuff and
maybe make your life easier yeah I think
I actually want to integrate it into
some demos that I have now I'm going to
integrate with some demos that I have
I'm already working on it and and it is
actually incredibly nice especially no
not having to deal with OAuth 2 yes
because it is not my thing anyway but
and then after that we'll have the
question of the week and today we do not
have the cool things of the week we have
the questions of the week yeah and I
have two questions of the week one is
related to a topic that we cover before
in a question of the week so how to
access meta data from App Engine the
second one is more about ok so I have a
bunch of different front and so my back
end how do I manage this thing to make
it reusable and a simple as possible but
before that we're gonna have the cooling
of the week which is about a German
philosopher Kafka I don't know if he's
German now actually I have no idea
actually I think so uh
let me check because I'm almost sure a
philosopher francisc is looking on the
air so if you're not familiar with
Apache calf koala friends ask is looking
things up it's a messaging system that
is very popular for a lot of people open
source we have pub/sub as a managed
messaging system here on google cloud
platform but a lot of people do use
kefka in an outside of Google cloud
platform and he brought in German but he
was actually from the Czech Republic
from the austro-hungarian Empire an
information for everybody important
information I like import information
but yeah basically what we are
announcing which i think is really cool
is the fact that if you are a kafka user
you're going to be able to integrate
very well with a bunch of our
technologies so one of the ones that I'm
the most excited about is the fact that
you can integrate it with Club pops up
both ways so you can send from pops out
to Kafka and back but then since you
have that there is a bunch of all the
things that also work one of them is you
can use it as a source for bigquery so
you know you can streaming to be query
using top pops up you can also do it now
with with Kafka and finally there's also
the possibility of doing the same thing
streaming to Apache beam or dataflow
actually data flow and apache member
pretty much the same thing ya know i
really like this because if you want to
put pub sub in your workflow you can so
you can go to pubs up and then pops up
to a number of different things like
bigquery or data flow but if you don't
want to have another messaging system
within your system maybe for complexity
sake once you make your life easier you
can go straight from Calcutta data flow
or straight from Catholic app to
bigquery which I think that's really
really cool yeah it is it is very
interesting especially for those that
are already using Kafka and we're
considering using things like be query
for big data analysis and understanding
better their business I think it's a
great opportunity absolutely I really
really like it yeah and we'll have links
to both the blog post and also all the
code which is on github so you can go
check it out absolutely cool well why
don't we go talk to Dan and set about
endpoints sounds good later that cool so
I'm very excited to welcome
den cerulean sep Ibrahim today a product
manager in a software engineer to the
group lapa from podcast hello how are
you doing hello doing great I'm doing
very well thank you hello so we're here
today to talk a little bit about Cloud
endpoints but before that I would like
to know a little bit more about who you
are so could you tell the audience who
are you and what do you do at Google's
so we can start with you then my name is
Dan cerulli I'm a product manager on
Google Cloud endpoints and Google's API
infrastructure I've been here for about
three years and my team not only builds
endpoints but builds all the
infrastructure that serves all of
Google's API is virtually all of googles
ap is nice what about you except great
so I'm sepa braheem said and I'm a tech
lead software engineer I've been at
Google for about three and a half years
and i work on end points and the API
infrastructure it previously worked on
compute engine and other cloud products
everybody excited to be here chatting
with you guys ok cool so Cloud endpoints
recently got re-released or released
again or enhanced it has it's different
its new tell us what Cloud endpoints is
now what does it do endpoints is a cloud
endpoints is Google's API management
product and you're right there's a
previous incarnation I'm sure we'll get
into it a little bit it used to be a
feature of a pension and it's now a
product on its own right and endpoints
lets you manage your api's and by manage
I mean you want to get information from
them know who's using them how much
they're using them you want to be able
to control authorize things like that
Google Cloud endpoints is what lets
customers do that on google cloud cool
so basically it's going to allow me to
provide rest api s well there's a lot of
ways for you to provide rest api's right
yeah i don't know what your favorite
language is python let's say it was
Python you might want to use flask or
Django to make a REST API you might like
a language where people don't use
frameworks so much to make kpi's and
that's okay what we want to do with
points is control who has access to that
API and give you really good monitoring
information about who's using that API
and how is it healthy it's okay so it is
not much as about serving an API as much
as giving like a layer of protection and
like authentication and stuff like that
on top of the recipe addict right if we
do we do have a couple of API frameworks
okay one in Java one in Python those
started its App Engine features they've
now been open sourced and can run
anywhere that's those actually are
lightweight frameworks that can help you
serve an API but most people already
have a favorite framework that they're
yeah we already have a language of
choice we know that we we want to be
able to work with anybody regardless of
language in front so if I got this right
so if I'm building a rest endpoint and I
want like common features say like
lugging or authentication or some other
things along those lines that's the sort
of stuff that I'm looking at so what
then are the like if you had to give
like out under four or five bullet
points with that tooling that I wanted
with endpoints is it logging you
mentioned authorization what what are
those what are those points so we did a
bunch of surveys before we got going
with this to find out what our customer
is needed and people use any use ap is
in a big variety of situations sometimes
it's the power their mobile apps
sometimes it's between microservices
sometimes it's for their partners to use
it but there's a certain core set of
features that everybody seemed to need
first of all is authentication right
when whether it's a service that's
making a call or it's a user that's
holding your mobile app or logged in to
your website you need to know on behalf
of whom that API call is being made
second is logging and monitoring ops are
very important status is very important
and you want to be able to know is the
API working is it working well what are
Layton sees scalability always comes in
really huge even customers who aren't
running at large scale it actually comes
in number one on their list of
requirements they want to know that if
it takes off if I become the next
Pokemon go if I even need a thousand
requests a second kenken this do it and
then the last thing is they want to know
who's making thought which developers
making the call every API call actually
represents two entities right there's
the developer who wrote that
ode you want to know that and you want
to know the user who's who's holding
that that mobile device interesting so
could you talk a little bit more about
that so you talked about authentication
and and who is doing it how do you how
do you explain that what are the ways I
can do that right so some of the ways
that Google's own API is provided
education to their consumers or with
Google's API keys and auth tokens and
service to service off and all of those
ways are actually available for
endpoints service producers as well so
if you have your own API and want to put
your own mobile app in front of it you
can use the same authentication
mechanisms that you would use if that
mobile app was calling one of Google's
api's nice well we mentioned previously
dan that there was a previous version of
endpoints that works with App Engine so
are there any limitations
technologically in terms of how I can do
my rest endpoints now or is that just
like a free-for-all can I put it
anywhere it's a free-for-all you can put
it anywhere we as you may or may not
know we were we are members and we're
founding members of the open API
initiative in the open API initiative is
is a bunch of people organizations from
around the internet smart bear who owns
the swagger project apogee Microsoft IBM
Capital One a bunch of different
providers came together and said we
should all agree on a specification
format for an API and there's a bunch of
reasons for that and maybe I'll get into
some of those but this this spec that
used to be called the swagger spec is
now called the open API spec is how you
tell us about your API so I don't care
how you develop it I don't care what
language you use I don't care what
framework you use as long as you can
give endpoints an open api specification
for that api then endpoints can can
manage the api for you cool all right so
well i'm going to redirect a step
because you're being really quiet over
there sure so but there are frameworks
that users have come out there's a Java
framework kind of Python framework what
does that give me a
and beyond the tooling that sort of like
the infrastructure tooling that I have
available yeah you know I want to turn
your question around a little bit i
think what you're trying to ask is why
should i use end points i mean these
solutions and the problems that we
talked about are not new and there are
many other products in this space that
provide logging and monitoring and
authentication what should i do
endpoints and we talked about you know
the customer who suddenly has a lot of
success with their app and has a lot of
users well it turns out that need for
logging and monitoring and
authentication happens very quickly as
soon as you get a couple of hundred a
few thousand users it turns out your
users will care a lot about whether your
app is up and running or not under- your
FB i--'s are up and running or not and
at that point it's a little too late to
go spend a couple of weeks learning
about a logging service and a monitoring
service and then a separate
authentication framework what endpoints
does is it packages all of those API
management features into one solution
and it tries to reduce the amount of
work that the developer has to do in
order to integrate with each one of
these features one by one by aggregating
all of them and say you focus on your
core competency pick any framework you
like pick any language you like and
build your back-end ap is what we will
do is we will provide you all of these
features and all you have to do in order
to take advantage of them is provide an
open api specification for your api
right so what is it that you get from
the framework specifically the
frameworks allow you to annotate your
code and generate that api specification
from it and then you can choose to use
the API management features or just use
that open api specification to generate
clients in different languages that can
call your api or take advantage of other
features like wavy you is that let you
explore your api does that answer your
question yeah I think so it sound
like basically the frameworks make it
easier to come up with that swagger or
pin API spec rather than trying to like
write it by hand for example would that
be correct yes cool so the way you
explained it I think it's very
interesting because it really sounds
like there's basically a bundle of
features that are opinionated and it
makes your life easier as a developer it
really sounds like a pension and to me
an app engine also comes with some
constraints right what are the
constraints other than the fact that you
need to use an open API or so I will
respect for endpoints is there anything
else that we should know I will redirect
that too that I think yeah no I don't
think so um in some ways our frameworks
are opinionated but I would say that the
the use of the open API spec is is in a
sense to avoid opinionation' if that's
word we want you to be able to choose
your back-end and by the way Cloud
endpoints I'm surprised we got this far
into the podcast before I mentioned it
bad product manager runs on App Engine
but you can also use it from compute
engine you can use it from container
engine you can and you can use it from
wherever the the proxy that that
performs the API management features is
designed to be containerized and
deployed anywhere so nice one of the one
of the big requests we had from existing
people who are using our frameworks was
they wanted to move to a pitch and
flexible environments they wanted to
move to container engine now now they
can do that for a nice so goody work
also on a bench in with other frameworks
other than Java and bike that's a
fantastic question and the answer is not
yet but we're working on that we're
working with we need some work from the
App Engine team we need some work from
our networking team as well but we would
love you to be able to be a pic you're
your own favorite framework down that
unhappen yeah this is going to take a
coordinated effort but we'd love for
that to happen is that a restriction
that's specific to App Engine standard
or App Engine standard and flexible
flexible and you can do anything ok so
flexible is fine all right so it is just
like if you for instance if you have an
app engine app Bryna go on standard
environment for now it could not work
but you could use flexible any good work
that's absolutely right in fact that's
why they call it flexible because it's
it is more flexible that is actually
among other reasons that's a little not
a little known fact naming right there
so we've talked a lot about rest api is
here but as many people who listen to
the podcast know we're huge fans of grp
see can i use this with gr pc said yes
you can actually our grp see support is
coming very shortly it is currently in
the Alpha stages and our customers can
sign up to use that and their advantages
to using gr pc and other advantages to
using json rest so you'll have to see
which one is the right fit for your
application i was actually really
pleasantly surprised at how quickly we
got that question from our alpha
participants and how readily they
adopted it you know it's sometimes a
little bit hard to gauge the success of
an open source project grp see in
particular we don't know how many people
are using grp see it's more than I had
thought then and yeah we want that same
feature set because whether your your
API is talking rest or not you still
want logging and monitoring you still
need authentication you still need API
keys so you want that same dashboard
regardless of what that protocol is
right that really cool now actually
quite curious since gr pc is kind of an
hcv to binary spec like protos coming up
do you get any introspection into like
the data going in and out or anything
like that does you get any cool tools
that way you don't right now in fact in
either whether you're using a rest JSON
or grp see we're not introspecting your
payload okay so we're not looking at
that payload in in either case but we
can tell you you know what percentage of
your calls are errors per method you
know what you're Layton sees are like at
median again / method you know which if
you've got a lot of which which client
is making the call and maybe maybe you
realize hey our errors went up but it's
all in a particular method and it's all
from only the iOS client yeah so that
lets you tell very quickly okay this is
probably a client problem with the
release we did so is it how do you
manage exposing a swagger an open API
spec when what you are using a grp see
how does that work grp see has a design
language you want to take prime f you
want to take that set
so our grp see customers inside and
outside of Google are currently using
proto to define their api specification
very currently working on integration
with open api for grp see services using
tracker extensions for example and other
options but internally what we do is we
convert the api specifications to the
same common format and the api is views
for that conversion and exposing the api
specification have also been published
so if you're curious you can take a look
at the amend the these would be under
our service management API set yeah we
can and we can also make a will put in
the resources section a link to the
github project so we have this this
thing called the Google API compiler
that can take an open a api
specification or a a proto and a yam all
that together describe how to how to
manage her a grp capi they compile them
to this thing we call a normalized
service config and that's actually the
the format that all our downstream tools
take so so one thing we would like to
see and we're you know as members of the
open API initiative we are working with
could there be a single canonical
representation of an API regardless of
whether it's HTTP JSON in nhv 11 or you
know proto and HTTP to so you know as we
work with with that committee the open
API technical committee we'd like to see
if there could be a single
representation but for now it's either
an open API spec or a proto nem oh
that's really cool now I'm just thinking
about how we were talking about the grp
see gateway that will switch to grp see
you can pull into an HTP cool so then
you can put a end points on top of both
and right that's pretty powerful and
certainly we will you know we're doing
that internally at Google a lot of our
API is now are serving both the grp sea
serpents as well as and JSON surface and
and we'll have that for sure yeah we we
had a we had Brandon Phillips last week
talking about how they use grp see
Icarus and they also mentioned that they
were using the grp see gateway
rice very nice to hear obviously I know
that because I listen every week as you
should yeah the nice thing as you
mentioned is that you write your back
end and it typically handles either gr
PC or rest but once you use endpoints
and have that extend the extensible
server proxy in front of your back end
you can transport back and forth and so
your clients are free to use whichever
suits their needs better and we do want
to work with thee with the standards
committee on making sure that it's a
canonical transformation that that that
you are describing completely with
either one of those documents what your
API surfaces cool I had a question
regarding one of my least favorite
topics which is off to what other kind
of authentications you have that you
talked about one of my favorite ones
which is API keys because they're super
easy to use do you have any other
options yeah so we do support get kit or
fire face off nice now we support other
third-party authentication providers
like 0 0 am I missing any other is that
no I think those are the important ones
and and you know both of those firebase
odds and r0 are used by mobile
developers especially who want their
users to login say with Facebook or with
username and s bird or you know your
twitter login or your github blog and it
doesn't matter they have integrations
with those so your end user maybe they
just log in with Facebook both those
solutions will generate a token a JSON
web token that is passed across
endpoints can validate it and say yes
this really was generated by your client
it's it's an auth token that's valid and
here's your user ID out of it so you've
got options there so if you've got
something like mobile clients and you
want like that particular user to be
logging in and then also if you're doing
maybe like service to service like
you've got those right and that's one of
the interesting things we saw that many
of our customers are actually doing two
types of auth they've got they've got an
external facing service that is
validating a user generated auth token
say the user login with Facebook but
then that's in turn calling
microservices and so they're using
endpoints on those micro services as
well and those are taking service to
service so their gender
validating an auth token that was
created in one of their other services
yeah yeah at least from the point of
view of the client calling the server
having things like fire based off is so
much better just because you don't need
to handle your the of to dance by
yourself and that is a huge thing I I
don't know a single developer that is
happy to write that part of the code
ever right no no one wants to do yeah so
both of you have actually mentioned this
thing called an extensible server proxy
or something along those little lines
this one you want to tell us what that
is and why is it extensible and why is
it a proxy like what does it do sure I
can tackle that so as I mentioned we
want the developers to be free to choose
any language and framework that they
want and build and host their api's
anywhere so what we're providing is this
extensible server proxy which is an
engine X based web server that sits in
front of their applications it's
extensible because currently it provides
features like authentication monitoring
and logging in the future we will be
adding other features to it that our API
management customers are looking for and
it's also extensible in the sense that
as you know engine X is an open source
project and we are working towards open
sourcing the proxy as well in order to
have the open source community be able
to take it and add other features that
they want one interesting thing about
about the way endpoints is architected
it's different than virtually everybody
certainly every other cloud providers
solution is that our proxy is designed
to be containerized it's not a what we
think of as a fat shared proxy where
every customer is calls api calls it
going through the same one and then
being routed to your back-end rather
this is a thin container that gets
deployed along side with your back-end
internally at Google we made a switch
from a shared proxy to a what we call it
distributed or server local proxy about
two years ago we did it for performance
reasons it reduces by an order of
magnitude the amount of latency
introduced at the
see it reduces a network hop and it's
and it's much more scalable so here
although it's a nice thing about it is
the decoupling if you have multiple
api's or multiple microservices talking
to each other you can update the proxy
setting in front of one of them without
affecting the others that's a very good
point so just make sure I'm
understanding this it that means that
rather than having that exposing Cloud
endpoints IP or people go always there
and then behind it there may be a load
balancer and then be handed a bunch of
machines what you're saying is that you
could still have basically the same
architecture where you're exposing an IP
from your load balancer and then when he
gets through every single machine those
machines are running a proxy that's
right think of it is it's just another
container running on those machines and
if you're using say gke or a pitch and
flex we make it trivial that you know
with App Engine flex that container just
just pops yeah just is there we see that
there's an API is part of your app and
so we spin it up we wire the the traffic
through it and so you really don't have
to do anything if you're using gke you
just say throw this container here but
yeah so and as your app scales and say
you you go from serving 10 requests a
second to serving a thousand requests a
second and you scale up that back-end
each one that comes up a server local
proxy comes up with it nice right I just
want to clarify though that even though
we're big fans of containers and use
them widely within Google and we're big
fans of the darker project you don't
actually have to use containers they
make your life a lot easier but if you
want to just deploy your code on a raw
GCE vm or a virtual machine somewhere
else you can let me do that too I like
that they make your life easier I mean
if you like pain sure yeah except you
said something kind of really
interesting but you kind of glanced past
it which is you said the proxies open
source into next project which the proxy
is based on is open source so that we're
working on open sourcing this but there
are a lot of challenges open sourcing a
very large project and I would say that
the challenge is where there's some
teams were aligning with internally at
Google it's a very interesting area as
well as outside one of the three
that that projects like grp see and
kuber Nettie's have done very well is
that we actually got partners in there
and working with the code before it went
to open source and it makes sure you're
in a certain state and so we're kind of
in that process right now there's a lot
of people very interested in this
project and we want to make sure that we
don't have to make too big of changes
after going okay with it so so we hope
to do something soon alright sweet right
then is that mentioned our tooling and
the implementation of the API is that I
mentioned are basically open source
right now it's very important to us to
not lock our customers in to say you
have to use google cloud or you have to
use endpoints we would like these
components to be able to stand alone and
for the AP is that expose the
infrastructure which is really doing the
heavy lifting you know it's the same
infrastructure that's running Google's
api's you could leverage it to host your
api's and take advantage of the same API
management features so that's what we're
really putting out there and we would
like people to be able to look at the
proxy code look at the tooling code that
converts and analyzes the open api
specification and also to be able to
extend it maybe contribute features so
that is mean that since we can run
endpoints basically anywhere i could run
the backend for a group Cloud endpoints
outside of the Google cloud yes that is
correct we are not providing
documentation and support for doing so
yet but it has work in progress nice
that I think that could be very
interesting especially for people
considering multi-cloud the fact that
you can with stackdriver you can have
monitoring multi-cloud and now with
Cloud endpoints you can actually have
also that on multi-cloud that is that is
very cool very cool indeed so we're
slowly running at a time not too bad yet
um I lost the standard question that we
always ask is there anything we haven't
talked about yet that you want to
mention or plug or talk about dan why
don't you go first well there is one
thing and and I think cuz your listeners
are really going to wonder why we didn't
mention it if I actually heard the name
once I did say it why I mention it we
did go on a little shopping spree last
week and bought a company called Apogee
they are one of the leaders in the API
management space and of course the
reason we haven't spent much time on it
is we told you going in because the deal
has been announced but not yet closed
regulators on this continent and others
prevent us from talking about the
roadmap so those of you who are
listening and hoping to get the inside
scoop here I can't say anything other
than this should make it clear that
api's are a big deal at Google and and
we are really you know excited about our
product line we're excited about the
acquisition and excited about the
possibilities so basically what I'm
hearing is you're going to come back
again once everything's closed 45 days
from now I'm gonna have a longer disqus
also thats a deal done except anything
from you I've just like to send a
message to myself a few years ago when I
was building a couple of mobile apps
that had a few thousand users and I
suddenly overnight had to start googling
for monitoring services and logging
services and how do i do authentication
and say that you know if you're building
a mobile app if you are hosting api's
let me give Google Cloud endpoints a try
I think you'll be pleasantly surprised
about how easy it is to set it up and
that you set it up once and you get all
the logging monitoring authentication
features with more features to be added
in the future so yeah give it a try and
you get the benefit of you get the
benefit of the open API tool chain as
well right so that's yeah that's
documentation generation it's explorers
to play with your your API and in a web
browser its client library generation so
there's a whole host of stuff that the
open source community is producing that
we're helping to produce now that you
get as well yeah all the cool things
that you ever heard about swagger right
are there that is that is very nice a
bit excellent well thank you to both of
you for coming on really appreciate you
taking the time it's been a really
interesting conversation yeah and see
you again in 45 days I probably of
course see you very much for doing right
now yeah that was a delightful
conversation
with both Dan and sep I really enjoyed
learning about endpoints I actually
hadn't had a chance to look at them too
much yet so it's really nice to come
here and do the podcast and hear about
stuff that's new and interesting on gcp
that I may not know about yeah we get to
learn a lot I had been involved with a
Google Cloud endpoints project a little
bit from the beginning but still I
actually did not know that you know
running a multi-cloud was an option and
stuff like that I think it's very
interesting yeah I I say perhaps they
yeah end up I've been sourcing some of
that stuff I think that would be really
really awesome I'm sure they will cool
all right so why don't we get stuck into
our questions of the week yeah we have a
couple of them I'm probably going to
butcher people's names but I will try my
very best we had two questions the first
ones from rashan dude over Ronnie I
would say so roshanda Ronnie yeah okay
cool hi rashan he has a question about
project level custom data Oh metadata
being able to access it from App Engine
he doesn't seem to be able to do it and
he was like hey Francis can you help me
because this doesn't seem to work for me
so yeah we we answer a question
regarding where to store information
like variables environment variables and
stuff like that a couple episodes ago
and we mentioned that one of the places
was the made a data service that has the
benefit that you can actually access it
from both compute engine but also
container engine and even a pension and
so to use it from my pension though the
important thing is that rather than
targeting the metadata googled internal
URL that is indeed internal and it is
not accessible from App Engine
unfortunately what you need to do is you
need to use the the compute API so the
computer bi is a REST API and you can
use it from anywhere as long as you have
the authentication and the default
authentication for app engine provides
that as long as you asked for the
compute scope and basically what you're
going to ask is you can ask for the
information about the project it is not
a made a dated thing it is actually
inside of the project resource you're
going to have a bunch of thanks in one
of them is all the metadata
variables attached to that project not
only to the instance so it is something
that you can definitely do it might be a
little bit confusing at the beginning if
you don't know where to look at it so I
think it was a question that was worth a
saying here so basically rather than
trying to access it like you're running
on compute engine access it like you're
an external service coming yeah
basically like if it was a mobile app or
something like that that's how you could
access it exactly the same way the good
thing is you don't need to really care
about authentication because the default
authentication from App Engine it is
good enough to access that that makes
sense cool and then yeah we had another
questions from Leonard Bennett Oh
Bennett I don't know it sounds good i
like it everybody that sends emails have
interesting that are hard to pronounce
which is awesome mine is not easy either
so yeah so Leonard asks ok so we love
Google cloud platform that is good pho
and they have an application which
they're running the back end on Google
cloud platform but then they have front
ends which are an Android app and iOS
app and then a browser web interface and
the problem is like okay we don't want
to write the code for those applications
over and over for every single time we
have a little change have to update all
our clients so how can we make this
better and to to reuse more code
basically and I think that you might
know about this so we might have talked
about it a little bit today yep i think
is really cool um so yeah if you want to
look at Cloud endpoints I think that's a
really good way to go particularly
because it conforms the swagger or
European ap naw ap i spec yeah the open
API is that gap and what's cool about
that is then you can generate clients
for it yeah and that's where I think
you're going to get a lot of benefit
from things yeah that is actually the
basically what Google Cloud endpoints
used to do for App Engine for java and
python that was exactly what I did right
like you could generate some open like
some specification which was not open
API spec it was a different one but from
there you could alter generate
JavaScript code objective-c code and
Java code with swagger or open API spec
you can do the same
but with many other languages which is
pretty amazing yeah i'd be interested
depending on what it is you're doing you
could also go down the grp sea route but
you may have some troubles there on the
web front yeah and depending on what
you're doing actually no I was gonna say
you could use go chris go can run both
on and oh and android and iOS but not
web yeah yeah so yeah probably not a
good idea there is a go to javascript
trans compiler I know go for two yes and
it is pretty amazing but still I'd
little italy too many producers yeah
little bit too many moving pieces but
yeah basically once you have one open
api spec or a grp suspect as you saying
basically you're gonna get the
possibility of also generating the
client libraries you can call that will
be specific for each platform and i will
make your life much easier yeah and
definitely listen to the beginning part
of this podcast if you haven't already
oh yeah absolutely cool well thank you
very much France ask for joining me once
again are you up to any interesting
things lately oh not really no no I'm
still planning my trip to Brazil that is
my next big trip I'm also going to be at
the beginning of October will be in New
York and I'm organizing a couple of go
events and I might be able to run a
Google cloud platform specific event but
we're still planning on that moon s I'm
gonna be wandering around Google's
having a google play indie festival so
if indie game developers on the Saturday
after this podcast will come out so i'll
be wondering about that just chatting to
people and saying hello that's not fun
where is that that's here in San
Francisco oh yeah I think there's a wait
list now so if you already registered
yay and if you're not you might want to
get on the waitlist and then a couple
have a link in the show notes do that
absolutely and a couple except for that
i'll be at another gaming conference
called siege where i'll be presenting
awesome sounds sounds like a fun week
absolutely well yeah thank you again
talk to you and talk to you all next
week see you then
you